LIFE AS A THIEF,
I REALIZED I WOULD
HAVE TO PUT MYSELF
AT GREATER AND GREATER RISK
OF LEGAL CONSEQUENCES.
MY CRIMES COULD
NO LONGER BE EASY
OR SIMPLY VICTIMIZE
THE OLD AND THE SLOW.
- EXCUSE ME.
- OH.
- DID YOU JUST TAKE MY HAT?
- NO.
HEY, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT?
IF SOMEBODY DID
TAKE YOUR HAT,
I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO HAVE MINE.
COME ON.
[laughs]
YEAH, WHY NOT?
I WAS SURPRISED TO FIND
THAT I WAS
INCREDIBLY TALENTED
AT SEPARATING PEOPLE
FROM THEIR BELONGINGS.
MY GOODNESS.
HEY, IS THAT JUSTIN BIEBER,
OR DOES SHE JUST
LOOK LIKE HIM?
NO, THAT'S HIM.
WHAT AN ANGELIC FACE
HE'S GOT.
THERE WAS NOTHING
I COULD NOT HAVE...
FOR FREE.
[siren wails]
[police radio chatter]
[light classical music]
♪
- GO!
- INSPIRED BY MY SUCCESSES
WITH PETTY CRIME,
I CONVERTED THE REVIEW OFFICES
INTO A STAGING GROUND
FOR MY MOST AMBITIOUS HEIST YET.
WE ARE NOT HERE
FOR YOUR MONEY.
WE ARE HERE
FOR THE BANK'S MONEY,
WHICH IS FEDERALLY INSURED.
I ENLISTED THE AID OF
MY EXECUTIVE ASSISTANT LUCILLE
AND OUR OFFICE INTERN JOSH.
WE WOULD NOT
GO UNPREPARED.
AS WE SAW DURING
THE FISCAL CRISIS OF 2008,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL NOT HESITATE
TO STEP IN AND BAIL OUT
THE BANKS...
- 30 SECONDS!
- WITH TAXPAYER MONEY, AND--
WHEN WE DO IT,
I'LL MAKE IT SHORTER.
IT'S TOO LONG. OKAY.
- IF YOU'RE THE HEAD TELLER,
RAISE YOUR HAND!
- WILL YOU PLEASE
BE THE HEAD TELLER, LUCILLE?
PLEASE. GOOD. OKAY.
- GREAT.
OKAY. TAKE ME INTO THE VAULT,
RIGHT NOW!
NO FUNNY BUSINESS.
- GREAT. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
WHERE'S THE VAULT?
- OH, IT'S OVER HERE.
- THANK YOU.
- GRACIAS.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
- GOOD. SO YOU'RE HEADED
TO THE VAULT.